[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar ai microscopy symposium seventh
edition
i am kayleigh bach of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by leica microsystems
to learn more visit
www.leica-microsystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i will now pass it over to luciano lucas
to introduce our speakers
thank you very much
for the introduction and it's really a
pleasure to be here today my name is
luciano lucas um i'm the director for
data and analysis here at leica
microsystems and we have a wonderful
lineup today of speakers
and
this is a topic that is close to my
heart of course and close to the heart
of leica and the team that
is represented here
the ai microscopy symposium is something
that started already some years ago that
in 2020 and thank you for uh all of you
that have participated in the previous
six sessions
and also thank you and welcome for
attending today's session uh wherever
you're joining good afternoon good
morning or good evening as it may be the
case for one of the some of the speakers
we have today are actually in australia
so it's very late for them
um if you're interested in looking at
some of the um presentations that
happened uh in the past uh they are on
the on our on the website on the avia
website uh you can see them right here
and
okay here
yeah here they are and there's quite a
lineup of speakers that attended
participated and presented their work uh
either uh exciting data set exciting
tool
or exciting a
new algorithm
for machine or deep learning
and we have all of them presented
present there and you can navigate and
watch any of those
today
we have uh three uh
four
speakers but three presentations uh
first from the university of melbourne
we'll have a vijay
and they will be presenting their latest
work
that is of course very very exciting and
it's the second time already they're
presenting here um ashfin is a
[Music]
currently at the university of melbourne
working towards his phd in still in
vijay's laboratory and they will be
talking about their latest work uh some
of it will include
the cell physio which aims to predict
the single cell biology they also have
worked recently on the em net uh which
is a deep learning uh for electron
microscopy image segmentation and i
think what is going to come up today a
lot is the cardiovinci
which shows building blocks for virtual
cardiac cell
cell using deep learning so this is all
very exciting this comes out of vijay's
lab and ashfin is a graduate research
assistant currently um vijay himself is
at the university of auckland uh
sorry melbourne sorry
my mistake
i'm looking at my wrong notes here and
uh he is the the principal investigator
for that presentation
the second speaker uh will be uh wikong
wu he's currently based at the nih uh in
bethesda he is there a staff scientist
already for a number of years more than
10 years
and
he gained his phd at the hong kong
university of science and technology
he he works with
hari sheroff and a number of other top
scientists at the
nih and they focus on
using deep learning to increase
resolution
or
increase the quality of the images
so i'm looking very much forward to this
this presentation as well and the final
presentation today will be from parmida
and she will be presenting deep leaf i
expect
or and sorry end crowd deep those two
presentations or those two topics are
are very important this is about
multiplexing looking at
how to use deep learning
for the analysis of images and then
extracting insights
from spatial data sets
so very exciting lineup of speakers
today
and
with that we should get started with
vijay
over to you
um hi uh thank you luciani for luciana
for your kind introduction
and uh thank you all for uh coming to
this uh
symposium it's a really exciting
symposium and i and i do want to thank
our organizers here for uh inviting
option and me
uh to present our research uh our most
recent research
um so let me uh get started um
what i'm going to be talking about today
what should and i are going to talk
about today is a new deep learning
pipeline called cardiovinci
um which is
which enables us to create uh
computer models of the cardiomyocyte
using uh generative adversarial networks
um before i get into or actually before
i let i shouldn't get into the
nitty-gritty details of it i just wanted
to give some context to what we're going
to present today
in the way
by introducing you to the type of work
that we do in our lab so as luciano
indicated that we're at the university
of melbourne i'm in the department of
biomedical engineering and our research
group is really uh i really exp have
expertise in creating
uh structurally and
physiologically realistic
models computer models of organs and
cell systems
and one of our research
aims
is
or research goals is to develop a
digital twin model
of a living cardiac muscle cell
what we mean by that is that we want to
construct
a detailed
structural model of
the ultrastructure of the cardiac
myocyte using
the latest electron microscopy and
super-resolution microscopy kind of
imaging techniques
we want to and within those geometric
models we want to define
mathematical equations and computational
simulations of calcium dynamics which
drive every heartbeat
we also are working towards building uh
more detailed simulations of the
energy energy requirements in the
cardiac muscle cell during each
heartbeat and indeed during development
and growth and disease
and uh of course the heart muscle
heart muscle's primary function is to
beat and so we all we're also
uh defining mathematical equations to
describe the mechanical contraction of
the cell
uh from different types of uh
biological data that are now sort of
exploding into our into our
uh research community uh thanks to all
the latest technologies
and so the thing that we want to do it
by implementing these different
mathematical models in the structurally
detailed uh geometric models is that we
want to take those models and then uh
generate insights
on
disease mechanisms that are that
the heart
sort of undergoes uh in conditions like
diabetes
uh heart failure so on and so forth um
and
uh when we're
when we work with these different types
of data invariably we have to deal with
uh different types of structural data
and electron microscopy is one of them
because we we get a lot of really high
resolution detail of the
ultra-structural changes that occur
inside the cardiac my site using this
technology and what afshin is going to
present to you today is our
the innovation that he's been uh making
in
helping us make this process of
incorporating structural detail into our
models more efficient
so with that i'm going to now hand it
over to afshin to present to you what
what cardiovinci is about um
thank you vijay um
greetings everyone um i also wanted to
uh thank luciano uh for organize and his
team for organizing this amazing
symposium
and
i'm just going to
walk through
the cardiovinci the methods that we have
used and the idea uh the main idea
behind the cardiovinci
that drive
that dry that drive us to
actually obtain a virtual 3d
reconstruction of cardiomyocytes
so um
the initial um
actually a driver uh for um
for
starting the studying
uh the cardiovinci and
the research that we went through
was basically that um we all know that
these days um with the advances that we
have and we see in electron microscopy
we can actually obtain
unprecedented and the large
three-dimensional views of cardiac
ultrasuctions or other tissues
but
one of the main challenges
during analysis of such data sets is
basically
that it takes much time to
extract
segment or even statistically quantify
or analyze
the 3d changes
in these tissue types as vijay said
we want to just expedite this process
because
we could have different conditions
different disease conditions
and
given that a variety of the conditions
that a cardiac cell could go through
we want to expedite the statistical
analysis and
and
just get
get more rapid
more rapid results in the 3d changes
that we can see in the cardiac
structures
um
so
having said that with all of these um
with all of these
advances and also
um and also
the limits that we face
in the 3d uh statistical analysis and
quantification
um we
we studied and proposed uh cardiovinci
as a platform and framework
that uses deep neural networks
to automatically segment and also
statistically quantify
the morphologies that we observe in the
cardiac cells
so
what is the workflow for cardiovinci so
basically
as you can see on the right
figure
um
it initially starts with the
segmentation of mitochondria
myofibrils
and z discs so
uh we are using um
semantic segmentation
as the first step
where we
segment mitochondria myofibrils and z
discs together
and
once we have segmented these
ultrastructures
next step is actually
feeding those segmented image slices to
train a modified version of the style
gang
and
i will i will uh talk about
uh why we have used star again um
in the methods section but um
so
once we have uh actually trained the
style again
we are able to project
the latent space
to obtain the projections and generated
images
uh
using the side the trained style again
and um
once we have generated these images or
these slice images from the style again
um
we
we are using jack distance
to
sort
the image slices by minimizing
mutual
jacket distance between the generated
slices
so
once it once the process of um
minimizing and minimizing objection has
been done we rearrange the can generated
image slices accordingly
to obtain a 3d image stack and
reconstruction
of the
cardiomyocytes that are actually
projections of the lathe in the space
and
once it had been done
we can obtain um
3d
shape and geometrical statistics
so we can quantify the changes in such
statistics that are vital to study 3d
changes
uh in the presence of the disease or
other conditions
um
so i'm going to just briefly talk about
the methodology
that we have um used in our study
so in for the data sets we have used two
data sets for our study
the first data set was basically a
publicly available data set which is a
forecast ion beam scanning electron
microscopy dataset for the controlled
cardiac
cardiac cells
and um the second data set was actually
involving a serial block phase scm
dataset
of the left ventricular cardiomyocyte
which was actually extracted from type 1
diabetes red
tissue sample
um
so once we collected the data set
and the curated data said you know
manually labeling etc etc
um
we
we when we uh we trained and tested
our neural networks
so
um
all of these um
all of these
training and testing had been done on
aws
and partially on a
high-performance computing
facility
called spartan at the university of
melbourne
and then the semantic segmentation
for the semantic segmentation
we use a modified unit with
uh
where actually we had
um
modified the bottleneck as a densely
connected conversion layers and also as
activation functions we have used
trainable linear units
and
we also finally modified the saw again
by introducing an auxiliary loss
function
to
minimize
the
to minimize the
distance between
one hot encoded image formatting that we
had passed along
the tf record data set to the network
so
in terms of the results the results were
interesting because
one of the results that were actually
one of the results that actually caught
our
uh
really attention and um that was uh one
of the main
uh i would say surprises in this study
was basically
um
the accuracy and the segmentation
performance metrics for the z disk
segmentation because
uh
most of you know uh most of you might
know that basically
z discs are really thin components of
the cardiomyocytes
and
they are really really challenging to
trace in segment
and
we had done previously we had
conveyed previously
a research around
uh segmenting z disks solely
and we showed that we showed couple of
results say that it is really really
challenging to segment
such components and mainly it is due to
um
data imbalance because
it is just comprising less than one
percent of your data set in your image
data set
and um but
when we use semantic segmentation
uh we notice that actually zeta
segmentation
shows really really promising and um
high
performance metrics
compared to mitochondria as it is as
shown to you in couple of important
metrics including variational
information
score and also
um
a couple of other metrics as shown to
you in this figure
um
the second result is definitely that um
[Music]
we
we could actually generate realistic
models of cardiomyocyte architecture
so the architecture that you're looking
at actually
uh is um is the generated and gen is the
reconstructed volume
using
generations
using generated image slices that have
been projected
from the latent space
so we have projected light in the space
slices and then reconstructed according
to an algorithm and according to a logic
which is
which is centered around minimizing
jacket distance between these slices
mutually
and um then we were able to um
reconstruct this volume
um
but on top of the you know the visuals
that we can see in those kind of figures
we
use couple of tests and also a couple of
metrics
to
where to validate our results
so we use anova testing
and
as shown to you on the left table
we have
validated a couple of metrics
geometrical metrics and also
geometrical statistics and also shape of
statistics in 3d
and we have compared
uh the results of what we have obtained
from gans and also
the real sample so we have compared
these two and
also
on the right image
you can see that we have
compared the mitochondria of
myofibril
relative
density frequency
by
sampling
a volume of
0.4 microns in each
axis
and
once we have obtained
that sort of volume we have just
calculated the density of the
mitochondria to my fibril volume
and obtain and obtain finally a
frequency distribution and you can see
that it is
exactly
fitting the same as the actual data set
so they are similar
in a sense
okay
so
in this video we have actually rendered
um
[Music]
a 3d version of the generated card in my
size so blue is z disks green is
mitochondria and red is my fibrils
and
we have also
rendered
um a limited uh
a limited uh i would say
a couple of slices uh
from the from the same volume to get a
closer look into how these uh are
actually how these components and
and
also structures
are um
are um
are actually
uh comprising this volume that we are
looking at so the volume that you're
looking at at the moment is actually
uh generated as the
um
gan output so we have reconstructed this
volume
from the gann generate the slices
and again
blue is z discs
my fibrils are
in red and mitochondria and green
and
i i presume that you all notice that um
mitochon myofibrils and z dicks
are actually
uh aligned in planes uh exactly similar
in in the similar form and shape
and
so
finally
so
as a result of cardio injury once we
went through the cardio machine proposed
cardiovensi we were thinking about
integrating all of our findings
and
all the methods that we had proposed so
far
into a simple and unique project called
cardia engine
so
the aim of the cardia engine as you can
see here in this image is basically
taking raw images
raw em images of the cardiomyocytes
and um
then
generating a geometric model
and once we have obtained geometric
model through channels like like cardio
injury
per se
then we want to obtain some
computational insights from the
generated volume as vj highlighted
before
so
that's the
um
the main idea
uh behind cardiointri and um
i would say um that um
we look to
we are looking to
actually integrate all of our findings
into this unique project
and finally and more importantly
i want to
thank our colleagues and
our collaborators
so
i want to thank professor
bodier
professor hanson
and dr brian glancy
for
[Music]
providing the data sets
uh for this study
and um also i wanted to thank you uh
thank april uh for
her assistance during the uh annotation
of our data sets and um huge uh thank to
definitely for
spartan facility at the university of
melbourne
for providing freely accessible
high performance computing to the
community
so that's from us and um
feel free to follow our updates on
twitter
thank you
very good
thank you very
much ashlyn that was
a very good update on on the progress
that you're making there are a couple of
questions that came in in the meantime
uh one of them uh comes from wong yang
choi um and
the question well i'll read out what she
wrote thank you uh thank you for the for
the great talk regarding cardio
vici what's different about cardiac
tissues that requires this deep learning
workflow and she has some suggestions
elongated muscles can this workflow be
modified for other types of
morphological detection
um
thanks for your question that's a great
question definitely um so
um
according to
our experience within last couple of
years
so
um we had another study on top of em net
which is called em stellar
in em estella we showed um that
these neural networks are sometimes
um tissue agnostic
and sometimes they are not so some of
them are actually showing really solid
and good performance metrics
for segmenting for example for example
mitochondria only but they fail in i'm
talking about just one t-shirt i'm not
talking about across different tissues
even in one single tissue
segmenting couple of components could be
challenging compared to the others as we
have shown many many times
but for your question
um i would say uh that the definitely
the cardiac cardiac structure
uh always is you know uh
always is amazing to me because you can
see the sort of repeated components
across the across your data set
and um that makes it
relatively relatively
i would say easier compared to neuronal
segmentation
according to our experience
but i would say depending on the
ultrastructure that you are
trying to segment or extract the
architecture for
or even depending on the delta set
itself
for example serial block phase
segmentation could be different to
forecast ion beam
data set and depending on the resolution
but anyway
um if i want to put all these together
i would say definitely the workflow
i'm not sure
what are you what do you mean by
modified because the workflow
we have already tested for diabetic and
controlled datasets and we have shown
that it actually works across two
different datasets which have
pretty much different resolutions we are
talking about 20 nanometers and 15
nanometers
so that's a huge difference
but um
in terms of the tissue type we haven't
actually tested
the the cardiovinci for other tissue
types
so
i'm not 100 confident that i can say you
can
absolutely apply to
um
different tissue types but that's what
we have highlighted in our paper and we
have uh encouraged the community to use
uh cardiovinci and apply to different
tissue types
and
hopefully they can get actually the
results
that are
statistically significant as we have
shown in our study so
i hope i have answered your question
thank you
there is no follow-up question yet so i
do have one question too for you
and the team right
i'm i'm curious about your experience
using gans you said that initially you
were using unets what was the role of
using the degenerative um adversarial
networks for for the project here
yes uh absolutely yeah yeah yeah yeah
100
so um you can imagine that um to
statistically quantify the data sets
you need to collect large number of
tissue samples
and
having said that um once we collect all
these sort of data sets we need to also
sit together sit and spend time
sometimes for annotation not essentially
because sometimes you can use some sort
of
um
transfer learning or you know tweaking
your cran network to segment other
teachers as well but anyway
if you have collected that sort of let's
say tissue types you need to spend time
around training
testing and deploying and finally
segmenting all the structure and then
quantifying in 3d
so the main driver for using gans here
was basically
is there any way that they can actually
quantify
the distribution that the data has been
generated from
and if i can actually if i can actually
so that's the main idea behind the gas
right
so gans are actually
um
[Music]
assisting us in
uh getting the distribution
of the data set
that
of the current data set that we are
dealing with
that data set could be generated from
that distribution
and once we have obtained that sort of
distribution
we can sample from the distribution
and generate
version different versions of the data
set that say that
that's that actually share
the same statistical properties with the
current offset that we are dealing with
so
the main driver for gan here was
basically to obtain
some
bakery generated cardio cardiomyocyte
images
that share exactly the same properties
as the
um actual data set or real dot set that
we are dealing with in other words we
are mocking
an algorithm or deep neural network
mocking in a way
that they are actually able to generate
realistically looking cardiomyocytes but
different from different i would say
um
angle and
we have all we have already quantified
and
statistically shown that um the results
produced in 3d
um
uh are the over results are actually
showing that they they they actually
represent and exhibit the same
statistics measure in terms of the 3d
drum 3d geometrical statistics and also
3d shape assistants
and this opens up and
we need to move to the next speaker but
this opens up the possibility if you can
generate realistic looking cardomyocites
uh in the in a somewhat deterministic
way it makes it possible for you to
train segmentation models also in the
deterministic point because you can have
the segmentation and the generated
uh cardomyocites as training pairs for
segmentation absolutely
so that's very
very very clever approach to to the
segmentation problem so thank you thank
you so much for the presentation
pleasure
thank you
and the whole team congratulations on on
this uh
several steps forward
since we last heard from you uh we will
uh go to the next speaker uh yukon wu is
is our next speaker um and um yeah and
then we'll be back for q a on on his on
his presentation as well
hello everyone i am ichong from nih
thanks for coming to this symposium and
today i will share with you our research
on the improvement of three-dimensional
resolution
in fluorescence microscope with multiple
deep learning methods
in this talk i will begin with the
background on image restoration methods
in fluorescence microscope including
classic richards and lucid deconvolution
and purely data-driven dependent
networks
then i will talk about our recently
developed methods richard st lucie
network ion now incorporates the image
formation process into deep learning
next i will show you their biological
applications including chaos arcane ddn
and rn to improve fluorescence
microscope performance
in that fluorescence imaging there is
always a so-called pyramid of
frustration with a limited photon budget
you need to trade off between the
spatial resolution temporal resolution
signal to noise ratio and how long you
can image the live samples before photo
bleaching and photo damage dominates
an image restoration with computation
methods can enlarge this pyramid
microscope image usually looks blurry as
the true object o is blurred or
convolved with the point spread function
or forward projectors of the microscope
f and then added with noise either
poisson or
gaussian noise and which of the century
the convolution method has been widely
used to explore
the recovery of microscope images and
this is the iterative process and here
shows the equation
and if you have an initial estimate a
you first convolute with the point
display function and then compare with
the measure the image
and then you convert this division with
the flip version of this forward
projector and then you update your
estimates get a new one and you
iteratively process until you get
converged and usually this requires tens
of iterations or even a thousand
iterations to get fully converged this
ek
through the true object
and recently we developed a richardson
deconvolution method with unmatched
backup projectors to speed up this
process
the idea is to use a new term backup
projector b to replace this free
perversion of the forward projector and
we found out that if the product or even
the convolution term between the
backward projector and the four
projectors is close to a delta function
all their frequency domain the multi
multiplication close to one then we can
achieve the full convergence
with one iteration
but both neutral distance loosely
convolution methods and um much the
backup projectors has some challenges
the first one is a computation testing
and regular one you need to large number
of iterations in some cases to
deal with those noise data you you want
to introduce some regularization term
and this will cause actual
computation
and even with our new variants and match
the backup projectors we need to
carefully design the parameters depends
on the different microscope different
numerical apertures and different image
quality in both
methods the stop stopping criteria
remains the problems and these stopping
criteria is quite subjective usually you
just manually
visually check the image quality at
different iteration
steps
the purely data-driven neural network
has also widely is proud to restore the
microscope images and these methods
including
includes content aware image restoration
networks care which user unit
and residue channel attention networks
are kind that we have collaborated with
daika and s vision to develop a 3d
r can shoot the noise to improve the
solution 8 and beyond the diffraction
limit we also develop a dense deconnect
ddn based on the convolution against
deconnect benz nets which can
also deploy images especially for those
blurred with especially value in the psf
all these
neural networks
has some challenges and we feel that
interoperability is a problem because
it's just a black box you don't need how
you don't know how the trend is in the
medium state in the medium step and
generalization abilities and other
problems you want to turn
a prior model to another different data
set of different structures it might be
difficult
so recently we developed richard sandus
in net worth ion the income combines the
forward and backward projectors in uh
the convolution term and the fully
convolution structures of different
learning networks and here is ion iod
let's
go through the iod again we can split
this into four steps the forward
projection step
the division part
then the backward position and then we
update and in iron we also have these
four steps and this ion is consisting of
three parts h1 h2 and then merge this h1
and h2 so in h1 we downsample the input
data by a vital 2
and then run the four projectors with
multiple kernels but small corners
and then we run do the backward division
backward positions up sample back and
then update the estimates and then we
get a new one e1 and for in h2 we use
the original data but use this kernel
with this layers and do the same this
four steps we have then we get e2 then
we combine the e1 and e2 as in the third
h3 and with this design h1 and h2 can
provide complementary information so
that we can maximize the use of gpu
and here i want to show you the rn
interpretability under conventional test
that means the
training data set and test data set has
the same structure this example is a glp
level the cell membranes in a c elegant
embryo acquired with that sheet
microscope and here compares the lighter
view and isoviews and iodf p1
is the first at the first iteration and
fp1 in ios in h1 block
and this is backup projectors back
backward projectors in ion and then iodf
five iterations and i
f4 projectors iod in the h2
block
and backward projectors and here is iod
output and ion predictions and you can
see that these intermedium steps at ion
is very similar to the iod this means
that we will incorporate these
iods into medium steps into the network
and that means this network becomes in
term
in term in in pre-turbo
and nia shows the
generalization test and the test data is
a human brain phantom
and the training data is different than
this data set is just a
synthetic a phantom object consisting of
different structures like dots spheres
and some horiz structures and both
datasets are blurred with the same psf
and again we compile the letter view and
iso views at different inter medium
steps and you can see that these
intermediate steps are very closed
between iod and ion and then rld higher
end prediction results actually
outperform the iod i will show you in
the next few slides
but we here we compare the learning
parameters and processing time of rn
versus other purely data trade driven
networks care archive and ddn
the
learning parameters between i and the
ddn is closed but it's much less than kl
and arcan is one over only one over 60
and for the training time it's close to
ddn and care by three times faster than
rcam and for a prediction time ion is
four times faster than k and give us 50
times faster than rcam
so here we compare the image restoration
performance between these different
networks and here is a fluorescence
piece under the conventional test and
lighter view and ico views
you can see that
care arcana and ddn no matter in the
metal view or isoviews you can always
see some distorted recovery
but iron is better
close to the ground shoes and here is
the phantom tissue
under the
generalization test
and here shows the zooming region of
these iso views and you can see that
only our income will predict these sharp
structures and iod care are kind of ddn
or fails to predict these dots
and we quantitatively analyze the ssim
and psnr values and farmland in both
this case of this brain sample case ion
give us the highest ssm values and psnr
values
and now i will show you some
applications of this rn and here is a
wifi the data with a sales and this
generalization test and the training
model was based on the synthetic
phantoms not the real structures of
these cells and the red color is
mitochondria and green is 18 blue is
tubulin and yellow is the nucleus and
here is a raw white field and this the
thyroid rich at the same lucy it results
and this is our n predictions and this
panel shows the zooming region and in
lighter view and also in a nice review
you can see that i am prediction can
better resolve these fine structures of
these filaments can bet can better
separate
and
because these outer focus can now well
be
decomposed with this iod but ion can
better
shows this
recovery's results and this example is
the same with wide field microscope by
the thicker sample it's ac elegance
embryos expressing tts3b gfp they label
the different neurons and when you
compare the raw data and ion output you
can see that ion prediction can well
separate these neurons and for single
neurons ions also outperforms iod these
fine structures of the new line can be
well recovered then
iod
and you see this gut region
you also see that this
line intensity profiles over these
membranes you can better see
see the ion can separate these neurons
otherwise law is too blurry to see
and also you can see that this improved
enhancements known occurs not only in
metal view but also a nicer view
now i will show you our applications of
these rns
and here is a dual data sheet microscope
based beam we have developed this system
quite a few years ago and the idea is if
we introduce the data sheet from left
hand optics then we collect the signal
from right hand camera this way you'll
get good data resolution but the i3
solution is poor and we alternate the
excitation from right hand optics then
this poor isotope solution becomes good
letter of view from this left hand
objectives so if we can merge these two
views into one then we can get
isotropical resolution and our algorithm
is to use was using join a deconvolution
so again if we have a single view
we have an estimate and then we use this
estimate to go through the
second iteration compile with the second
views uh measure the image and then we
get updates we alternate this process
and eventually we can get isotropic
solution at 330 nanometer at all three
dimensions
so this one shows the compass the neuron
developments in c elegans between the
single view that should audioview data
sheet in night review and ico view you
can see that the fine structures of this
new light were better resolved with
these uh stereotypes beam and this still
view need to register this true to get
this isotropic resolution we need to
register the dual views and then join
the convolute so we are thinking if ion
can predict these dv images from a
single view input and here compares the
k arcane and ddn on u2 cell
transferred with tom 20 that's a
mitochondria and you can see we compare
the raw ground juice that's the dual
deconvolution grant use ion arcane ddn
and care and you can see that only ion
can better resolve these fine structures
while
the ddn or r can i care fails or cannot
greatly improve the iso resolution and
here shows the time-lapse
of i o and compare with the raw data
and just with a single input single view
input we can predict this nice
resolution in lateral and iso resolution
we have also used dice beam to image
dodge the clear tissue and here is an
example of most brain tissue
labeled with some neurons and cleared
with idisco and our multiview fusion can
enable isotropic submicron resolution on
this large data set
and because the data is so big so we
cannot directly register through
dataset that's almost terror by its data
so our processing processing pipeline is
to
run a course registration and then crop
the
big data into
maybe thousands of volumes and then long
final stations join the convolutions and
then stitching back even we use the back
project how much the backup projectors
we can still need 3.4 hours to process
this data set so we are thinking how can
we use ion to speed up this processing
so here we shows that the
rm prediction on these neurons and again
we compare with the r n care archive and
ddn and you see that in the better views
the predictions are very close but in
iso views care will mix some structures
rm can pre
bring some extra noise only ion can get
based
similar to the ground choose
and again if we calculate the psn ssm
and only the i n can give us the highest
value of these also including the
mitochondrial data
so here we test on an even large clear
mouse brain tissue and it's all about
neurites and these colors indicate code
different depths and it's called
different lateral positions and if we
zoom in a small region and combining the
law in lighter view and nicer views and
you can see the ion prediction is quite
close to the ground shoes not only in
these fine structures but also in a
frequency domain
and
compared to our previous processing
pipeline as i mentioned the restriction
crop financial joint convolution
institution without this iron can
improve
to six times and faster than these
pre-processing method
and most important joint deconvolution
need to do registration of the two views
so in some cases in some small some
volumes if joint deconvolution fails due
to the error
restriction or some hardware value then
we
reduce those details but ion just rely
on single view input so we can well
reserve preserve the structures and
recover the resolution in these views so
here shows the entire
3d volume rendering and this is the raw
data
and then the rm prediction you can see
it becomes sharper
and then if we compare with the
joint conversion you see that in some
cases they are very close because if the
good decision but if not
it fails you see the
structures
are missing
in the
in the joint deconvolution but still
will predict
with the ion
so if the
volumes are contaminated by severe noise
so ions cannot fully recover the
solution although the right reach
the convolution totally failed ion can
predict but not as good as the ground
choose
and if we just use arcane to denounce
the data it's also not as good as the
ground choose so we adapt a two-step
deep learning first using our can to
denoise
then use ion through deeper and then we
find out these two step depending can
best recover this
er structures and this is confirmed with
ssim and psnr calculations
so in the following slides i will show
you more applications about these
multiple step deep learning approaches
on other microscope so the first example
is multiview 9 confocal microscope
confocal microscope is a very powerful
imaging tool to image
scattering samples stick samples
but the isotropic
the dissolution united dimension is not
as good as the vital dimension and the
second one is a point the illumination
and point scanning makes the 3d image
very slow so we develop a lancome focal
microscope and also with a much too
extra views
so this example is uh
it's a
tubulins on a fixed sales so when you
see from the top of views is quite
primarily along this dimension from
right hand objective it's blurry and not
and along around the dimension and in c
views along this y dimension of this z
dimension and again we use joint
convolution method to combine these
three views into a single one
and then you can see that the resolution
after this trigger view deconvolution is
greatly enhanced and here shows the
trivial view the convolution results and
the color indicates different depths and
here is the external essay view
and here i show you some live
applications of this live convocal image
and this one is
minor con metal tracker green and the
lyso trigger diploid
and compiling the draw and the trigger
view deconvolution in lighter and ico
views you can see that the trigger view
combination can greatly improve the
resolution
and this is the cardiomyocyte label with
mitochondria and same thing you can see
that trivial will improve is the views
but the challenge with the distributed
income focal is the speed because you
need to acquire three views and these
previews will also
cause extra photo breaching photo damage
so again we try to use deep learning to
solve this problem and we use a two-step
depending methods and the idea is for
each view with the noise first we create
the denoising models
and then based on these denoises reviews
we joined the convert name should run a
retrieval view the convolution to create
a ground truth then we train another
model from this denoised vc bottom view
to these
three views one choose to get the
convolution mode
and in application we only need to one
bottom views denoise and then apply to
this deconvol model you can also just
train one step mode of just directly
from this low snr view see to this high
triple view deconvolution and here
compares
the results on a gop histone in cl
against embryos from the raw view just
one step depending two-step deep
learning and ground choose triple view
and you see that only the true step deep
learning can best
resolve and recover these structures and
one steps also shows some artifacts and
this is confirmed with the ssim and psnr
values with two-step depending we can
get a ssni value of 0.9 but with ssm is
only 0.7
so
this
two
step deep learning methods has allowed
us to do live convocal imagings on the
sierra against embryos to monitor the
nuclei development in the entire for
150 minutes
minutes which otherwise is impossible
with the triple view lancome focal
microscope and here we compare the raw
and to step deep learning as 3d
projections and here's the maximum
intensity at different time points and
you can see that the two-step depending
can recover many missing signals with a
single view
acquisition and this training and
prediction is based on care
and here is another example that this
two-step deep learning enables uh like
vocal imaging and also outperforms the
dice beam again we
monitor the development of these aib
interneurons in the novel in
the brain in the c elegans embryos and
comparing the raw
to step deep learning nitro and isoviews
and you see that these fine structures
are resolved and recovered with deep
learning prediction and this 2d step
deep learning outperforms the dice beam
a similar time stage and these allow us
to monitor the growth dynamics at the
tip of neurites over the entire
embryogenesis
so
in the trivial convocal microscope we
can improve the resolution by structured
illumination because we use line
scanning and if we modulate the line
scanning intensity along this around the
scanning direction then with some photo
reassignment method we can get super
resolution along the scanning direction
so in this case we
improve the resolution along this
dimension for the view b along x
prime direction in the view a and v c
along this y dimension and these three
dimensions provides complementary
information so that we can get good
resolution in all three dimensions and
here is an example of
on expanded worm embryos in lighter and
iso views you can see these neurons and
neural structures and when you compare
the super resolution mode to the
diffraction limit mode you can see that
resolution is greatly improved compared
to this draw
but the problem is that the resolution
is only enhanced along the scanning
direction and from this optical design
we are now able to get the isotropic
um
dissolution enhancement in implant
so we are thinking to use deep learning
to solve the problem and the idea is
that if we have a confocal input
and we can train this confocal input
with this 1d sim results right and
once we build this one dc model then we
rotate this input at different
an arbitrary angle and apply this one dc
model to these
rotated images and we find that the
resolution enhancement always occurred
along these
i don't want dimension
and then when we don't tell this this
the
the image back
then the resolution enhancement occurred
at different orientations and then we
joined to convert these
different orientations like here we use
six notations then we can get true
dimensional which simply resolve the
images rather than just 1d
sim results
and here shows some examples of
microtubules so this is a raw data and
here is the frequency domain and here's
the zoom in error regions and after
uh five phases
the constructions we get super resolved
along this y dimension
and with deep learning we can predict
well predict these dimensions and we use
when you rotate the image
the draw the diffraction limit input
and then apply the model and then rotate
back we found out the resolution
enhancements occurs at other directions
and then we join the convert these
predictions and create the two
dimensional sim and when you see compare
these images you see these filaments are
where better resolved than just a single
directional seam and this shows the line
profiles these two filaments can better
separate with 2d sim otherwise it's
blurry with 1d sim or the raw data
so we apply this trick to all three
views
and
now then we get trigger view to the sim
so here is a live example with the itin
and you can see that the tree triple
view 2d sim
can greatly
improve the resolution come relative
compiled to the raw and we find out
there is a 10 force improvement and here
the training and testing is based on our
chem
and we applied the same method the same
deep learning trick to sticker samples
on uh
warm adults and here is about a dense
nerve ranged regions in the in the long
in the membranes
region and here compares the raw trigger
view deflection limit just one view to
the same and triple view to the sim you
can see that the 2d sim trueview 2d sim
gives us the best structures and
sharpest details
than just even single view or
division limit and
so these true combination of the
hardware and
the
deep learning results enable us to see
these very very details and which is
otherwise impossible with the existing
microscope
so the second example is a structured
illumination microscope and that's a 3d
sim and the four beam sim so here shows
the excitation pattern of wide field and
then if we introduce three beams from
the back focal plane of oppositive then
we can create the this structured
illumination pattern not only in lateral
dimension but also in iso dimensions so
here in this case you can double the
solution in x y and z
and if we follow user mirror to refresh
the beam to create uh interference of
four beams then we introduce more
higher freq modulation frequency and
then we can fully improve the resolution
and here compares the resolution
measured on 100 nanometer beats and
shows the
intensity profile along the z dimensions
you can see that 3d sim you greatly
improve
this this range relative to the white
field and for this sim can further
improve the resolution and we show that
with 3d sim we can get 120 nanometer in
lateral dimension and 300 nanometers in
ico dimension but
the four beam sim allow us to image to
get the same lighter resolution and in
boost the lighter the iso dissolution to
less than
550 nanometer
and this shows that four beam sim
enables near isotropic resolution in
biologic samples this example is a
materials comparing the wide field 3d
sim and four beam sim you can appreciate
that these fine structures are only can
be seen with these four beam sim
otherwise it's blurry with 3d sim and
impossible with white field
and these line clear files follow
confirm we can resolve these five
structures and this example is
outer membranes of the mitochondria and
the color indicates different depths
again we compare
the 3d similar 4bcm at different
lighter positions and iso positions and
you see that is greatly improved
in icl view but the trouble again is
that
to use to get this
nearly isotropical resolution we need to
use a mirror and it's very hard to
implement for live imaging and also
cause issue photo beating and photo
damage so we seek to use the deep
learning method
to
to improve the ico re solution and the
trick is similar to the white to the
multiview confocal microscope the idea
is to blur
the natural dimensions so that it looks
so that the solution in later dimension
is similar or close to the ico
dimensions then we don't sample and up
sample
the the sample to minimik
mimic the real z acquisition and then we
train the model from these input this
data to these 3d sim ground choose and
then once we have
model then we up again we rotate the
input at different angles at any
arbitrary angle apply these models then
we get
we can improve the solution
like this always
increase along these x dimensions and
then with the tape back then this
resolution
occurs at different
orientations and then when we run the
frequency domain you can see that the
resolution occurs at different
orientations we must we take the massive
value at each spatial frequency and then
inverse the fully transform and
eventually we can get good night we can
recover the
isotropic resolution in 3d sim and here
is just some comparisons is mitochondria
you can see the
the 3d sim and 4b sim and the deep
learning methods based on the 3d sim you
can see that this
this better resolve these five
structures than four beams seen
and here's another ducati examples based
on fibroblasts and carbon 1 and carbon
at 1 and you see that 3d sim results you
cannot see these details but deep
learning predictions can see these
horror calls and different kinds of
structures and this is very
close to the em results
and again for three dimensional same
imaging we need to
uh combine multiple inputs to request
with unite the construction to get a
high quality results but for live
imagings you cannot get a
good
uh
low height with high sena
and to image longer so we use denoising
step methods and again we develop
multiple denoising steps the idea is to
denounce each raw images together first
the denoising model and then based on
this denoise the images we will not
construct the 3d sim and with the
highest and now we directly construct
this as a ground choose and then train
the second model and this method is
better than if we just use the 15
raw snow sni inputs as a as input and
these highs and led construction as an
output
so here we compare these uh different
methods from low snr high standard
ground juice and two step r can and or
one step i can from 15 input you can see
that only these two steps are can
can provide the best resolution than
this one step with arcane or this one
step with density on it so if you
combine this denoising step and
isotropic model we are able to push the
limit in three-dimensional silver
resolution images and this example is
live cells with them one and nitro
tracker and you can see that the low
low lowest and nasty construction
servers many
artifacts but these two-step denoising
isotropic can follow these dynamics
so in summary we have shown ion has
interpretability and is similar to iod
in the medium output and this iom
provides a better faster decommosion
capability than those purely data driven
neural networks
but multiple step depending is required
to deal with those low snr images and
iom provides four to six volts speed up
over the pre
pre previous processing pipeline for the
joint convolution of large volumes
acquired with a divorce sheet microscope
and this method can also completely
bypass artifacts introduced induced by
poor restriction between views
and last we show the multi-step
depending approaches using kl on kind
ddn and ion can improve voluntary
resolution in different
fluorescence microscope including our
recent develop
multiview convocable resolution
microscope and 3d structured
illumination microscope
finally i would like to thank our lab
chief dr harris love and other lab
members who contribute to this project
pluto and srison and our collaborators
inside and outside nih who contributes
the ion
uad and total view in xiang university
in china
and thank you for your attention
thank you so much
econ that was uh quite a tour of the
force uh as always very very impressive
to see your presentation
and to see the latest
from the from the lab
i do have a few questions let me get my
notes back in front of me
where did they go
we can hear you perfectly yes perfect
so
this is absolutely breathtaking uh
and it seems like every couple of slides
we are uh presented with another amazing
um
kind of step forward
in
in compressing that triangle that you
presented at the beginning so you're
systematically figuring out ways
to make it possible to do high
resolution
temporal and spatial resolution
and do it quickly without damaging the
sample so it's
impressive um and uh and really a
pleasure to watch
i do have
one about accessibility
because this is
um
it seems like a very
custom-made
piece of hardware and a very custom made
piece of software so what are you doing
to make this more accessible to the
broader community because it seems like
such a powerful set of tools and
developments that you've created
now um so we so this
splits to a few things for example the
dice beam actually has been
commercialized and people can access
this system
and even there are mainly so-called
multi-view datasheet microscope and i
think they can use
the they can train
if they can acquire data wrong
whatever the ground use and the other
thing is as i mentioned in ion it's
quite generalization
so you don't need to be very specific to
the structure you are imaging you can
create the synthetic phantom and just
blur the with the with your system psf
so that's another way you can do
so
regarding our recent
paper about the multiview united states
microscope and structure the
immunization microscope uh yes i do
agree that hardware is quite hard to
to copy to
but we also try some something funny
something interesting thing so we apply
the model trend with our
microscope on our vocal and then apply
to those commercial uh spinning discs
and then the model works it also improve
the lighter resolution including seo
resolution so it's amazing
at this moment
and for the last part about the 3d
structural illumination the key point is
we can improve the ico dimension and i
think that's very
powerful we haven't tested for other
modality but we believe this same
trigger can be used for any
microscope
if they they want to build everything
then is from the lighter view phone to
improve the ico view so i believe this
is not limited to our microscope it's
just the method if you can apply if you
can get
the training data set by by your image
and and feel that you don't need to
need a bunch of training data sets maybe
10 or 20 volumes is sufficient to do to
recover the resolution yeah
and we also hope we hope but use data
can commercialize our system
so
yeah
thank you for the the hint um
so
one of the
as you as you say tricks that you're
using is stacking of deep learning
models and you do kind of one step for
denoising another step
for the the joint deconvolution and
others and sometimes the third step but
is there
can you give some intuition
uh
why is that better
than just doing end to end in one go so
you might
you might
sometimes not have the ground truth i
appreciate that the the end point ground
route but sometimes you have it so when
you do have the endpoint ground through
and the input data why not train a model
to go all the way to the end instead of
multiple
models to to do each step
yeah i think this is a good question we
also we are also possible by these
but we think that because a single
neural network can
use this need to optimize the kernels
right and some kernel is only for
denoising some kernels only for
deburring the convolution so if you
train names together then kernel will
just need to be compromised so you
cannot get the best results but even for
this even with just our kind you just
two steps three step and each network
just optimize or learn its own base the
kernels the different layers then maybe
combine that this is this cassette is or
sequential maybe give you the basic
results so that's all i always feel
okay
unless maybe you use very deep networks
maybe you can you can learn more right
you can just watch that but
right indeed i mean
maybe it wasn't clear to everybody but
these are not particularly deep and you
you're not training with a tremendous
amount of data so this is really
uh kind of
usable by the general the general user
of microscopy it's not a google size
type of project
it's a reasonably easy to get amount of
training data and you can run these
algorithms on a good computer locally
you don't need huge cloud resources
yes yes i agree with your point yes so
you split it to multiple different small
tasks that might be easy
so one last thing um
more going looking into the future
you've made together with the team
tremendous progress in the last five
years in this in this
ai microscopy world
um what kind of experiments would you
say are now possible that weren't
possible five years ago
first part and the second question is
what do you expect will be possible in
five years that right now is not
yeah i have to say even five years ago i
was
i'm just a i'm a microscopist i'm not
any deep learning computation guy but
five years ago i would i attend a deep
learning course and then i just a lot of
times is hot and then we think okay how
to use the deep learning to improve our
imaging performance right so at that
time we start to think and then we are
very lucky to have a collaboration with
you and then develop these so many
permission to us
and so if five years ago we definitely
cannot imagine we have these especially
when we do that when we
when we try to implement the multiview
confocal microscope you haven't thought
about the deeper learning but then once
we're data we
change and then we seek the use of
dependency and then we can
achieve those results
and for the next five years good
questions we never know and then
let's see
okay all right um very good thank you so
much uh we come pleasure to have you uh
on on the ai microscopy symposium
thank you so much for your time and
all your insight now in the q a um i
will
thank you one last time and we'll
progress to the next speaker our next
speaker
is
pardeema
and she comes this is dr pradeema
mani sorry for my
pronunciation
she's a senior data scientist at the
memorial um slow and catering cancer
center in new york uh and
she did get her phd
from stony brook university and also has
a master's in computer science as well
as a phd in computer science so
absolutely expert
we'll be hearing about some of the
developments that she's been involved
with and she's been involved in quite a
few exciting ones including neurons
construct which we'll post in the chat
in a moment so you can check it out
and deeply
which is uh part of the story today so
without further ado uh i pass it over uh
to pradima and i will be back at the end
for the q a final q a session of today
thank you
hello everyone thanks for having me
today my name is parmitah garamone and
i'm a
senior data scientist at memorial's
longer in cancer center
today i want to talk about deep life a
multi-task learning model that infers
more informative image representations
and at the same time segments and
classify the cells for more accurate i'd
say quantification
interpreting images of tissues and cells
at a resolution higher than the naked
human eye is the core of pathology
and essential to diagnosed diseases
due to the rapid progress of medical
imaging techniques over the past decade
pathology has been improved considerably
by creating digital slide scanners
that can capture
whole slide images
pathology plays a vital role in cancer
diagnosis and treatment
the pathological analysis is performed
based on the visual interpretation of
the tissue sample under the microscope
to the difference in visual perception
and clinical training
pathologies can have conflicting
opinions
about the cancer diagnosis and treatment
over the past decades
computer vision and deep learning
approaches have been developed to assist
pathologists in assessing tissue
sections
the computational pathology has several
challenges
the first challenge
is the large size of the whole slide
image
for instance a single image acquired at
20x magnification
can contain billions of pixels
while the area of interest can be as
small as a few thousand pixels
the next challenge is the lack of a
universal image format
currently there are
various holoslide image scanners from
different vendors
for both bright field and fluorescence
imaging
that capture images using different
compression types sizes illuminations
objectives and resolutions
and output them
in different file formats
the next challenge is the high
morphological and color variants
and having
artifacts
and the last challenge is the large
amount of time and expense required to
obtain expert drive labels images
computer vision has been used for many
tasks ranging from low level such as
edge detection to high levels such as
complete scene analysis
in the last decade there has been lots
of improvements in artificial
intelligence
because of major progress in deep
learning tons of advancements in gpus a
release of large labeled datasets
the application of deep learning in
medical image analysis involves various
tasks including object detection
segmentation classification and
registration
immunohistochemistry called itc
is used in histology to detect the
presence of specific protein markers
that can assist with accurate tumors
classification and diagnosis
where hne and special stains are
non-specific
ihc is directed to a specific protein
marker
pathologists look for the presence
or absence of particular markers
multiplex immunofluorescence called
empire
is used for simultaneous detection of
several target proteins
in the same cell
decrease complex spatial information of
a tumor
or tissue sample
and it can be used to visualize the
spatial distribution
of proteins within a single cell
typical workflow of ic quantification in
commercial tools such as halo
consists of several steps
first i'd say that the convolution needs
to be performed on the input itc image
then
nuclear are segmented in the hematoxylin
channel
next a threshold setting is found for
the brown dubstep stain
to separate cells from the background
noises
and finally the cells are classified
based on the threshold found in the last
step
here we present deep life
a simpler workflow for itc
quantification
given an ihc input image
deep live generates four modalities
and the classified segmented mask
deeply performed hc quantification in
just one step
and it does not require error prone i'd
see the convolution or manual
thresholding steps
deep life is a multi-task deep learning
technique that uses co-registered itc
and mpif data
to simultaneously
translate low-cost ic images
to more informative mpif representations
and accurately
segment
the cells
and classify them
for more accurate and reproducible itc
quantification
given an itc input image our multitask
deep learning framework
simultaneously
infers the corresponding hematoxylin
channel
empire your dappy image that has
only the cells inside it without any
background noises
impair your flap to image which is the
new marker and shows the boundaries
around the cells
and then mpif marker image
and finally
the classified segmentation mask
where the red cells
show positive protein expression
and the blue cells
show
negative cells
the first had to align the ic images
and employee of data
to create our training
so we designed a registration framework
and core register
350
ic pairs of bladder
and
350 pairs of long data
our training set
contains pairs of
hematoxylin
dappy
lab2
marker and segmentation mask
deep life consists of several components
the main component of deep life is gans
which are generative adversarial
networks
cans are used for generating synthetic
data
it consists of a generator that captures
the data distribution
and a discriminator
that estimates the probability that a
sample is real or fake
we use residual networks for
the translation task
it consists of
residual blocks
and it has skip collections skipping the
training
from a few layers and connect directly
to the output
in the segmentation task
we use unit structure
which has shown great success in
segmenting biomedical images
it's a fully convolutional network that
has a contracting path
to capture the context
and a symmetric expanding path that
enables precise localization
deep life consists of two main parts
translation task which is used for
inferring the modalities
as you can see here given
an itc input image
we have
four generators
that
infer hematoxylin channel and mpif data
including dappy lab2 and the marker
image
the generators
in the segmentation are in the in the
translation task
our residual
networks
then we have the
segmentation or classification task
which is used for generating
the classified segmentation mask
here we have five different generators
that create a segmentation a classified
segmentation mask
from the input id image and the infrared
modalities in the translation mask
and then using evaded average
module creates the final classified
segmentation mask
the generators in
the segmentation task
have
unit
architecture
for each
generator
in the translation task and in the
segmentation task
we have a corresponding discriminator
to address high frequencies in the image
we use a patch can discriminator
that only penalizes a structure
at the scale of patches
meaning that it classified patches in an
image as real orphan
so we run this fully convolutional
discriminator across the image
averaging all responses
to provide the final output of the
discriminator
to optimize our network
we alternate between one gradient
decent step
on discriminators
and one step on generators
in all defined tasks
including translation
classification
and segmentation
the network generates different
representations for the same cells in
the input image
meaning that
all tasks have the same endpoint
therefore
we use a single optimizer for all
generators
and a single optimizer for all
discriminators
using this approach
optimizing the parameters of the task
the more clear representation of cells
improves the accuracy of other tasks
since all of them are optimized together
at the same time
in the translation task we have four
generators to infer hematoxylin channel
tapping image lab2 and the marker image
from the given input itc image
we have a discriminator corresponding to
each generator
which is responsible for discriminating
the generated images by that generator
the objective of the conditional gap
in the image translation task are
defined as you can see here
we use smooth l1 loss
to compute the error
between the predicted value and the true
value
since it's less sensitive to outliers
and then we calculate the objective loss
function of the translation task
based on the
conditional gain loss
and the
l1
loss
for all generators and discriminators
in the segmentation classification task
we have five generators
producing five individual segmentation
masks
from the original ipc image
the inferred hematoxylin image
invert empire of dappy
invert lab2 and invert marker
image
then
we calculate the final segmentation mask
by
averaging vape by calculating a weighted
average
of the segmentation mask generated from
these five individual segmentation asks
again we have one discriminator
corresponding to each generator
in this task
here we use a scan loss function as it
solves the problem of finishing
gradients
for the segmented pixels on the correct
side of the decision boundary
we again use smooth level loss and so
the objective loss function
of the segmentation classification task
is calculated using the
l1 loss of the
calc final segmentation mass that's
calculated here
and the l scan
loss function of the final segmentation
mask and the discriminators
the final objective of the deep life
is calculated
using the loss of the translation task
and the objective loss function of the
segmentation task
we
tested
deep life on different testing data sets
the first one is the pc dataset
which contains k67 stain sections of
brisk carcinoma
with positive and negative cell centroid
annotations
so we randomly selected
41 images of size 640x640
and segmented all these images
then we split these tiles into 164
images of size 512x52
we also tested deep life on nucleic data
set with a publicly available cd3 cv8ic
dataset
we use the nucleic training set
containing
671 itc patches of size 256 by 256 that
all are extracted from the lyon 19
dataset
to evaluate our model against
state-of-the-art methods
we define these metrics the first one is
the pixel accuracy which is calculated
from the number of the true positives
and false positives and false negatives
we also calculate a dice score which is
giving more weight to the true positives
we then calculated
the intersection over the union
metric
but
we calculated it uh for each class and
calculated debated
the average of these
iou for these classes
we also calculated aggregated jaccard
index
with object level metric
meaning that
we calculated the iou for each cell
separately
then
uh because actually the
goal of deep life
is itc quantification
we calculated the itc quantification
error
which is the difference between the ic
quantification percentage of the
predicted mask and the real
testing all these methods
on the pc data set
you can see that deep life
outperforms
the state-of-the-art models including an
unit recently published in nature
a mask or cnn that has shown great
performance on semantic segmentation
tasks
unit plus blocks
linknet and fvn
and
also if
uh
it has a deep life has less error
in itc quantification
compared to the rest of the
models
here
you can see two sample images taken from
the bcdx
the predicted classes are shown in
different colors
where blue
represents
ki-67 negative
and red represents
ki-67 positive cells
and the hue is set using the log two of
the ratio between the predicted area
and the ground earth area
cells with two large areas
are shown in dark colors
and certainly two small areas are
showing a light color
for example if the model correctly
classifies a cell as ks67 positive
but the predicted cell area is too large
the sun is colored in darker
and if there's no cell in the ground
truth mask corresponding to a predicted
cell
the predicted cell is shown in yellow
which means that the cell is
misclassified
it means that still segmented correctly
but classified wrongly or mis-segmented
meaning that no cells in the segmented
set area is available
here you can see two example images
taken from the pc data set
and the infrared modalities generated by
the deep life
and here you can see the results
generated
by deploy and the state of the art model
and as you can see
uh
deep life
outperforms
the state-of-the-art models
in terms of the aji and pixel accuracy
in these two examples
and you can see it also
uh that the segmentation and the
classification
uh
is more accurate
using when we use diploid
uh we tested deep life on ihc images of
various markers captured in different
clinical settings
we visualize the structure of the
testing data set
by applying t-distributed stochastic
neighbor embedding
to the image styles
tested on the deploy
to do that we first extract the features
from each image
using the vgg16 model
and then we apply pca to reduce the
number of dimensions
in the feature vectors
next we visualize the image data points
based on the extracted feature vectors
using tsne
as you can see here
the training data set
has completely different characteristics
compared to the testing data set
and yet
deep life is able
to adapt to images
with various resolutions color and
intensity distributions
and magnifications
captured in different clinical settings
and successfully segment and classify
the heterogeneous collection of the
testing sets covering eight different
markers
and you can see here the classified
segmentation mask
and
as shown
deep life
can accurately
segment and classify
all these
uh
images which has different staining and
are taken from different markers
we also tested deep file
on microscopic snapshots
from a digital microscope
that was stained with
k67
and pdl markers
on the right side
you can see one sample image
of the pdl bob marker and on the left
side you can see one sample image of the
k67 marker
as you can see here
a
diploma
is able to infer the modalities
and accurately
segment and classify these microscopic
snapshots
we also tested deep life an nwn 19
challenge data set contains
441
hc
cd8
breast colon and prostate
region of interests
with various staining and tissue
artifacts and they were collected from
eight different institutions
unfortunately
they have not provided the annotations
as you can see here
deep life
again can
infer the modalities
and segment and classify
the images
of the cd3 cd8 marker
uh
fit
artifacts in them and different staining
uh
and taken from different tissues
um while it's only trained on ki-67
uh marker images
we also tested deep live on patented
data set
which
contains ifc
k67
breast cancer images
and it contains manual centroid
annotations
which are created from the consciousness
of multiple pathologists
these images
were acquired in low resource setting
with microscope camera
and as you can see
deep life is able to segment and
classify the cells
with more than 95 percent accuracy
we also tested deploy on human protein
atlas
by ck 67 dataset
this data set covers 6 different cancers
from patients with
different genders and ages
and it actually covers
different type of staining and intensity
and i put a different
idc quantification score
as you can see here
deep life
can give you an exact itc quantification
score
like this which is 49
where pathologies
only provided a range for the
itc quantification score which is 25
to
75
so here we deep life we can have more
accurate i'd say quantification
we also tested deep life on hne images
and surprisingly
deep life
can segment the hne images
while it's trained on itc images and
it's because the
deploy
first infers the modalities
including a hemotoxin typing and lab to
image that would help in segmenting
the pathological images
after training
the first version of deep life
we figured out that it has issue
in separating positive cells
in cluster of high
contrast positive
cells as our training data
lacks this kind of information
so
we designed our ihc generator model
it gets three images hematoxylin
dapping
and the classified segmentation mask as
the input
and generates the synthesized idc image
and its corresponding marker image as
the output
after training our model
we generated synthesize idc images
with cluster of positive cells
by converting
the negative cells which are shown in
blue
to positive cells which are shown in red
and then using this ic generator model
that we already trained
uh
synthesized i'd see images and their
corresponding markers
as you can see here
this is the original image and its
segmentation mask
so we
randomly selected some cells from the
segmentation mask
and converted them to positive cells
and then we used this model and
generated these synthesized idc images
and their corresponding markers
we also
synthesized
staining
and intensity of ic images
by changing the contrast
and intensity of the hematoxylin image
and then using this model to create the
synthesized idc images
the first
there are
different ways to use diploi
the first one is our github repository
you can access the code and the
instructions how to use this code and
to run your data using the pre-trained
model or if you want to use the tip live
to train it on your data set
we also have a website that you can
easily upload your images
and
it gives you the inferred
modalities
and the classified segmentation mask as
well as the
ihc quantification score and number of
the positive and negative cells
we also have an image a plugin
that
gives you more options
and more features for example as you can
see here you can select a region of
interest to do the segmentation in that
region
and then you can
uh change some thresholds like the cell
size or
uh the probability of the
cell to
uh
be a cell exactly or not
and
so using
our plugin you can get
the best version of the segmentation
mask the one that fits your needs
uh this concludes my talk
thank you for joining today
i look forward to answering any of your
questions in the q a session
joining today
i look forward
hello
hey welcome back uh thank you so much uh
for the the presentation that was um
quite special it was one of the first
ones we had
uh
focused on this topic of multiplexing
and virtual staining uh ardima
congratulations on the on the work that
you're doing together with your uh group
um i have a few questions that some of
them have come in others i have myself
i'm
curious about
uh let me get my notes here
back okay
uh one of the things i'm i'm curious
about is um
the so you you've shown how to do this
for nuclei it looks like it's mostly
nuclei detection segmentation and you
can predict also the fluorescent markers
this is already a huge step forward i'm
curious if you have tested this versus
other methods like you mentioned halo at
the beginning
other standard not machine learning
methods
and also other machine learning methods
like cell poles or stardust which
use different neural networks but are
pretty popular in
the life science
space maybe not so much in the digital
pathology space so i'm curious about
those tests i saw the ones you have on
the paper and the ones you presented
today but those are specific
networks not so much a a full pipeline
like uh like cell phones or stardust
they have really tried to optimize the
whole stack to make good segmentation
so that was my first question
uh first the uh question about the halo
yeah we tested halo we tested some other
uh frameworks as well and actually we
found out that uh
this deep life outperforms
those
segmentation
algorithms as well
and about the cell pose
cell pose and deep cell
are designed to segment the cells in
dappy images and mpif images
not itc images
so deep live somehow is the first one
that is trying to segment the ihc images
which is much harder actually one of the
things that we tested is that to
collect the segmentations for the ground
generating the ground towards data set
for deep life we actually tried those uh
deep cell and cell pose and halo
on our on the dappy images because you
cannot generate some preliminary
segmentations with ic images there are
not any available
uh model that can do that uh very well
uh so uh
yeah and actually that p segmentation
segmentation the dappy channel is much
much easier than the ic image and uh
yeah it's
it's impossible to compare our model
with a deep cell and sell pose because
we are doing
different things
i see okay sorry there i was muted there
i appreciate that
what about the the allen cell institute
so they they do go from
it's not exactly the same thing because
they're looking at
transmitted light instead of
humanistic chemistry but there they also
transpose so that's also a different
approach it wouldn't make sense to
compare there never mind so
very interesting another question or
another topic related to what you showed
um and i think you kind of touched that
on on the on the paper
is
what is the feasibility of going uh
towards the detection also of different
uh organelles and other types of
labeling not just the nuclei or the
membrane which have a
pretty clear representation uh when you
look at
immunohistochemistry but not so clear if
you're doing let's say mitochondria or
some other you know physical of some
sort or er or any other organelle
what about those do you think those will
be possible to predict also from
immunistic chemistry to get the pseudo
fluorescence and then do segmentation of
those or that's beyond the technology
currently
no exactly that's what we are uh right
now trying to use the apply for we are
actually using we have um
the deep life in its version that you
can see in the main github repository
only doing some specific things like
generating the hematoxylin the pe marker
and lab2 and the classified segmentation
mask
but we also have a configurable branch
in our github repository that is
actually
the goal of this branch that we tested
on different data sets different type of
works because we don't want to generate
only the
these four type of images we what we are
actually right now are doing is uh
testing it on
another data set and just uh trying to
infer the
uh immune marker and two more marker
from the hematopoietic channel only
and that's another thing that we are
testing with deep life and in the
configurable version you can just say
what what what's the number of the
modalities that you want to get and if
you want to do the segmentation or not
or do you want to do the classification
so it can be used in different
uh
projects and yeah it can definitely do
that i believe
okay and
one last one last question before we
closed off uh and
about
you know multiple labeling when you have
a high plex image uh with let's say 20
channels and and and
three or four of those represent a
particular region of interest
have you tried to create uh
segmentation that goes directly to that
using using this approach using your
platform so
where three or four channels are
representing a positive region not a
positive cell but a positive region does
that work as well with this approach
that's exactly why we have the weighted
average module and so with the weighted
average you can just set the uh value of
the those channels as zero in the weight
of the generating the final segmentation
mask and then they will not do anything
in generating the final segmentation
mask and that's what we do in some cases
very exciting
it's clear that the now the digital
pathology or spatial biology um
environment community is very very
active using uh using machine learning
to try and get
to better performance than before
like i was asking nikon in the previous
presentation i'm wondering where you
think this is going what is the future
in this space what do you think will be
possible in a few years time that isn't
currently possible
uh honestly by now there are a lot of
uh works that has been done for example
uh people are doing cancer even cancer
treatment using uh the results that the
deep learning models are actually
generating and so i think in and it's
been maybe
uh
less than 10 years that deep learning
has been introduced and uh used for this
uh
i mean even for the healthcare i think
it's maybe less than five years that
deep learning has been used uh and so i
believe that
in future in maybe less than five years
we will see a
large improvement in
the diagnosis and treatment
part of the health care
very well
well i'm looking forward to welcoming
you back uh at some time in the future
to see the evolution of of your platform
and uh and the applications of different
applications and models that you build
um thank you again for your amazing
thank you for having me
a pleasure it's our pleasure
um
so uh with that i wanted to thank all
the speakers uh including our melbourne
uh australia-based speakers vijay and
nashville who were the first presenters
today then we had econ
[Music]
presenting from the nih in bethesda on
the east coast of the west and and then
now we finished up uh with pardema also
on the east coast in new york city um i
myself i'm in lisbon right now uh and uh
the last thing i wanted to mention is
that we we will be having a future uh
ai microscopy symposium will be the
eighth edition we'll be planning that
for later in the year but very soon
we'll have the first the fifth
uh mecam live stream uh which will be
with me so i'll be talking about image
analysis uh it will be a live session um
the the aim there is to look at images
that are pretty complex then we do image
analysis there live
and also showcase some of the latest uh
systems that we have developed here at
leica specifically here we're gonna be
talking about mika which is uh the the
micro hub uh does both confocal imaging
as well as as as wide field we
deconvolution so it's a wonderful new
system that we just introduced uh
earlier this year and this particular
episode will be about image analysis of
images that come off that microscope
so with that um i want to thank everyone
that participated attended
and helped organize
um today's session
and i've passed it over to the the lab
groups team that has done a wonderful
job to to host us today thank you
thank you luciano and thank you again to
all of our speakers for their time today
and important research we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
leica microsystems for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
i'd also like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye
you